hey everybody
and welcome to a very special wild ride
with stevo
i think i've mentioned this before on
the podcast but
gosh darn does my signature look exactly
like
a wiener shooting stuff out and i say
that
because every single copy of my book
which i sell at stevo.com
is personally autographed and it's
filled with crazy stories like you are
about to hear
right now from me and somebody who's
been my hero since we were both
14 years old so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen danny way
yeah dude let me introduce to you my
co-host scott randolph
what's up brother and for you coming
from off camera
uh we have paul briskey hello yeah how
are you doing
i'm good man yeah dude this is a big
deal right here man
um for anybody who doesn't know danny
way man this
you've been my my hero since i was a
little kid dude and i mean
when i say little kid we're both pretty
much exactly the same age right what's
your birthday
april 1574 and i'm june
13 74 so you're
less than two months older than me and
when
when i first found out about you i would
have been 14
watching this epic skateboarding video
called public domain
and uh dude i mean i saw it in
i went to high school in england so we
got everything later you know like
i'm guessing that you probably had
filmed that
you know considerably before but it was
just crazy to have this kid
who was the same age as me and like
like just blasting onto the skateboard
scene
with powell peralta which was the
skateboard company
that tony hawk rode for steve caballero
the bones brigade was like
the only game in town and then every
year it was a big deal dude when we were
kids
yeah a really big deal and uh
living in england too i went to the
american school in london and uh
i think somebody like pulled a prank on
me they're like dude
like uh one of the new students next
year is going to be danny way
that's so funny yeah and i was like what
oh my god
when i was younger it's like you know i
would travel to different contests
whatever but i always
connected with the kids my age you know
i think they related to me the most so
like
like you said like you know whatever i
just i had like a coalition of little
kids that i bonded with everywhere that
were kind of you know like fans of
the fact that i was the same age and
doing this you know and make it happen
it was
pretty rad for sure brad yeah it's cool
you were like a child
star but in this really rad way not like
for being an actor or a singer but for
being a
badass skateboarder and it was
skateboarding was still pretty
underground in that
era so yeah yeah skateboarding was super
underground
in that era yeah who scouted you for
that video how do you get into a video
like that for your first one
dude it all happened so fast but i was
you know like
i was skating for vision skateboards
vision streetwear
and and i wasn't too stoked on the
program
and they left me in las vegas at like 13
years old at a contest for real like i
flew out there they were supposed to
drive me back and then the contest
it and they disappeared i'm like i'm
sitting in vegas with no money no cell
phones back then and i'm literally
stranded
and by the grace of god this guy comes
along he's like dude i see you need help
and
you know i got your back and i'm like
yeah what's your name and he's like my
name's mike
mike mike chernanski and this dude flew
me home from
vegas that i just met didn't know at
that time he was going to become this
very important person in my life but
he got me home so so that that point you
know my mom was a little bit
pissed off about it whatever like i did
you know
crazy to be that young and end up in a
situation like that but when i was
growing up i had you know i was kind of
an independent little kid my mom gave me
that kind of freedom
trusting i you know would do the right
thing or
get home with you know get involved with
the right people where i wouldn't be
left in a place like
you know that far away in vegas but
anyways
i had the opportunity because eighth
street skateboards was starting up right
around this time
and i was hanging out at tony hawk's
house quite a bit skating his new skate
compound that he had built out in
fallbrook
and i lived kind of right by tony so i
just you know bucky was hanging out
there
bucky lasik and i started to see this
vision like wow like maybe i should
leave vision and ride for powell
but then mike ternanski you know i built
i had you know he'd flew me home from
las vegas free of charge just looking
out for me
you know starts listening to me on hey
we're starting this new project
and matt hensley was my friend i grew up
with and he skated for vision
skateboards with me and he left vision
jumped on h street this new startup
company right yeah let me let me jump in
here i know
people hate it when i do this but to put
into perspective
paul peralta was the company that danny
was amateur for
and and tony hawk wrote for them like
all the biggest names it was the biggest
game in town
and then danny way like 13 years old
like made
like all of a sudden decides i'm gonna
leave paul peralta i'm gonna quit
like the whole world is looking this
like are you [ __ ] crazy danny you're
gonna
quit paul peralta he says yep i'm gonna
quit paprolling i'm gonna go ride for
this company
that nobody's ever even heard of before
hasn't even been launched probably it's
called
h street they're like h street like what
even is it and why the
[ __ ] would you do that and uh and and
then sure enough it ended up it seemed
like the most reckless move
that like career-wise that danny could
have made it ended up being
like the smartest decision ever because
at that time
h street just took over it was this this
it was yeah i mean there was like
i i had the chance to get on h3 before i
got on powell because mike
planted those seeds and when we flew
home from vegas that on that flight
he was like hey i'm launching this new
project with tony magnussen we got brian
lottie
mike carroll and like and he was like
pitching it and he was like you know
we're talking to matt
hensley and i'm like well okay those are
my friends i'd love to be on that
program but
the bones were yeah dude you can't like
yeah nobody's gonna shake that vision so
i i had that opportunity and
you know i jumped on on powell um
because because the
opportunity opened up for me and i chose
to ride for powell over h street
but about a year into it you know and
believe me dude i was so blown away that
i even ended up on the bones brigade
you know that video part you're talking
about the public domain video part like
stacy peralta showed up and filmed me
that day with his own camera you know
on real film like he pulled up and
filmed bucky and i that day and it was
like
i remember after the session i'm like
you know i didn't even know if i was on
pal yet like i went up there
kind of like in this transitional period
with nobody yet telling me
you're on the team or not so i shoot the
video you know we skate all day and then
i asked stacey parolt afterwards i'm
like so
am i getting on the team he's like what
do you mean you're already on dude and
i'm like
whoa i've been stressing this whole time
like did i skate well enough did i pull
this off
so it was the biggest dream come true
but after you know a year of it like
if you look at the pecking order of
people that were in line you know and i
understand like they have some
you know some some celebrity pros on the
team and a lot of good young kids on in
in the lineup sure you know start moving
up
so like it just wasn't happening i guess
fast enough where i knew i could you
know i knew where i was at with my
skateboarding and i knew i could
i could take it to another level if i if
somebody got behind me
and pushed it further and so you know i
wasn't after a little while i wasn't
getting the things i needed to go to the
next level and mike
came you know like there was a contest
in houston texas
that was your first pro contest it was
my last amateur contest but it's a shut
up and skate
houston shut up and skate on this in
skate culture that was like back in the
day that was
like you know it was like the
underground grassroots backyard but
you know it's a skate park but backyard
you know ramp style
contest mentality you know just chaos
punk rock
partying the whole deal but the the you
know it was also
the one you wanted to win because it had
the most street cred
so as an amateur showing up at that
contest was everything to me and i knew
that was the contest i needed to win to
really put myself on the map to turn pro
right and i think in the first eight
street videos shackled me not they
showed you winning that contest
yeah and that was the day i started
writing a nate street board because the
story goes i i got so desperate
to go to that contest in the back and
the bones were powell was like we're
going to send you
and the last second they go no we're
boycotting the contest and i'm like
boycotting what the [ __ ] does that mean
you're boycotting it what are you
boycotting i'm going to get to this
texas bonus i gotta win that you know i
got to try and win this thing
yeah and they're like sorry we're not
going and i'm just like dude hensley
everybody's getting ready to get on
their flight
ortega all my friends i grew up the ride
for hp now my hometown friends so i'm
like feeling left out of my
my skate bubble like these are the
friends i skate with every day now
they're on a program they're doing
everything i want to be doing
so i started to get like pretty jealous
and you know it started eating me up so
i called mike up
and i'm like hey you know i know you
flew me home from the one event you
didn't ask for anything in return i
appreciate that but
dude i need help getting to this houston
contest like whatever dude from me
like let me i'm like so desperate dude
can you help me get to
texas he's like yeah we can we can make
it happen
but only if you ride for us dude
this was featured in the very first
eight street video which was called
shackle me not okay when i saw shackle
me not
like my head exploded okay and this was
right at the time
when i got my first video camera which i
stole from my dad's closet
and i made my very first skateboarding
video which was called
i hate rain but what's important about
this
is that i hate rain was the first video
made by team h road
what a [ __ ] funny my buddies and i
called ourselves team h road
because h street was that [ __ ] cool
like we didn't even care
like we made t-shirts that said yeah oh
yeah we made
h road t-shirts and dude i was i was 14
years old
riding a danny way skateboard like his
pro model
like i i didn't say h street on the
skateboard yeah like cross it out and
wrote road
no dude that would have been
disrespectful
yeah and so that's like how far back
danny and i go
i was riding danny's board in 1990 right
i graduated high school in 92
went to the university of miami i was
all flailing around
but uh i decided i wanted to be this
rad like uh stunt guy and my best plan
was to try to be in skateboarding videos
so i go to the skateboard convention and
i'm going around all the booths like
ejecting their tape putting in my tape
and that was like everybody was just so
pissed off until i got to the xyz booth
and that's the company that danny way
started with our buddy tommy
and i plug in my videotape on their
booth and tommy's like stoked about it
he's like dude is that you
and i'm like yeah dude we start
shotgunning beers next thing you know
i'm sponsored
by xyz what how old were you when that
happened
at that time that was the first week of
1997.
so i was 22
okay so that's like seven years after
that that tournament right so
yeah yeah i mean there's a lot there's
you know there's a lot of like
there's some more skate videos that came
out and some more chaos
and stuff but because yeah let's let's
get into that because you left
h street then right like eighth street
kind of like fell apart and you started
plan b
with mike ternaskey yeah i mean
eighth street was like a a prototype
project you know like
the guys you know tony mag and mike
ternanski came together they started it
and it was like
i don't think anyone anticipated what
what was gonna happen
you know like i i know that those guys
were pretty genius in how they pulled
what they pulled together
but i don't think they realized like how
big hensley was gonna be
and i don't think they you know i think
they sensed that i was gonna go
somewhere but
i think the synergy of having us at once
and us being new young blood
and having you know having this new
brand when pal peralta
and stacey peralta and the bones brigade
dominated skateboarding throughout the
80s in a certain way and 8th street
took all that away 8th street took that
all away from powell
and hc was the only game in town at that
point
but then i think what i hear you saying
is that now 8th street
they didn't know how big they were going
to get they didn't know like how
big the skaters were going to get and
all of a sudden it's like oh well
the skaters are going to see more
opportunity somewhere else it's going to
get pretty hard to keep them
unless you really you know respect
how big they are yeah and and or just
you know
listen to the guys that that that are
moving the needle for the project
and like tailor it so that everyone's
happy you know i think h3 got to a point
where there was a lot of like
difference of opinion on how it should
be or what it should look like or how it
should feel or whatever
so at a certain point instead of like
trying to spend so much time correcting
certain things we were just like you
know what let's just
let's just do a plan b and like start a
new project and like just
start it right like do everything you
know all the other things that we
learned
from from h street let's just do it
right this you know from
from the jump and not make those same
mistakes and keep it tight you know and
keep this
feeling in the brand that you know i
mean that was what created
a tree was the synergy of the of the
talent and the personalities and how
everyone kind of complimented each other
and got along
but you know when the bones were get out
you know stacy was actually a master of
this
this is where stacey peralta kind of
invented this formula and then mike
ternanski took it to another level
and then h plan b essentially was you
know our refined version of h street
is there like beef between the different
like companies like uh
absolutely before we get into the
intense beef between skateboard
companies
let me make the point that i've been
getting pretty rad lately
yeah and i might have needed some
surgery
but the good news is bed rest
is better than ever in my helix mattress
i'm telling you
if you guys haven't done this yet go to
helix sleep.com
stevo take a two minute long
quiz right where they're gonna match you
with the perfect customized mattress for
you to get the best sleep of your life
if you're in a situation like i am
needing to heal up a little bit
you you want to have the perfect bed
and that is from helix sleep.com
stevo go ahead and order from that right
now
and you're going to get up to 200 off
any mattress you choose plus
they will throw in two free pillows
and these helix pillows are the most
comfortable things ever
so again go to helix sleep.com that's
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com stevo get the best sleep of
your life
yeah dude now let's talk beef
it's like gangs meeting up [ __ ] games
in new york [ __ ] at all
at competitions
i think danny couldn't confirm or deny
this but i think with
i think it's safe to say that clearly
pal peralta was
just the biggest and the only biggest
and they were successful because stacy
peralta
was a skater the company vision that he
talked about before
was run by a guy who never even skated
you know
like that was the problem is that skate
companies were
being run by people who weren't skaters
you know apollo was good because stacy
pearls knew was going on
8th street was like a skateboarding
operation
and plan b but by this point i think
enough skaters got big enough
that you saw like really like you know
genuine
like rad companies run by skaters and
there were kind of
a bunch of them you know popping up so
there wasn't gonna be any more
one company dominated everything anymore
you know like
is that fair to say yeah i mean in the
80s
there was a coalition they called the
big five
which was thrasher transworld
pal peralta vision and nhs santa cruz
and those guys had like it was like the
u.n and they would come together and go
okay well how do we [ __ ] block all these
young new startup companies
and and monetize the retail level or the
you know the distribution model and
you know and globally dominate
skateboarding us as the group we'll
we'll dominate as a team you know so it
was those guys kind of butted heads here
and there
but you know certain you know we can't
forget about our good buddies steve
rocco i was going to say that
came rocco so i was going to bring in
rocco so rocco
rocco was also moving the needle at the
same time as h street
morocco came in with the more rebellious
mentality you know right
he was he was more like you know he
didn't mind
anyone trying to ruffle his feathers
because it just gave him good reason to
do some funny stuff back and
in return he won because it just drawed
more attention to world industries and
the santa monica airlines or
you know all the brands that he created
can you explain who rocco is
yeah we talked about this with ryan
shekler on this show
about how skateboarding all the money
that came into the skateboard industry
was sort of
conditional contingent on
my mom approving the the the
purchase of the product so the
skateboard video is up to that point
where kind of
kate like catered to mom's approval like
they didn't show like brutal slams
everything was just kind of like made to
be cute and like like okay for mom
and then 8th street came along and they
were like nah this is we're all about
the skateboarding
but then rocco came along and he was
like you know what
skateboarding is like [ __ ] criminal
like we've got we're out here breaking
like we've got this attitude and [ __ ] it
you know so rocco
wasn't trying to kiss mom's ass anymore
period he's like
i'm gonna actually bum out mom you know
we're gonna like we're gonna express
skateboarding as what it is we're gonna
take pride in like how [ __ ] up it is
how brutal the slams are we're gonna
have little kids like
[ __ ] vomiting all over the place i
mean his mentality was the more he could
make the parents
hate what he was doing the more the kids
would want it
genius and and you know and he is a
genius steve rocco is one of the
smartest most clever you know just
brand visionaries marketing guys so he's
done some
amazing stuff over the year i mean and
he's the catalyst behind jet jackpots
i was going to tile yeah i was going to
tie it together but you know the guy
that was moving the needle with mike
ternanski and
and steve rocco came in and he started
playing b with us
so mike rocco and i were kind of driving
this you know this initiative to create
because you know i left h street to
skate for blind
i jumped on blind which was steve
rocco's company with mark gonzalez and
jason lee
yeah you know jason the act you know and
they caught it blind because they were
saying [ __ ] vision it's
the opposite of vision skateboards they
said we're gonna call it blind
that's great i didn't really know i said
there was beef totally and steve rocco
was like
head of marketing and team and all that
stuff at vision
and he left vision to start santa monica
airlines and was like hey mark gonzalez
like when you're ready
cruise over like i got you know and as
as steve started to succeed i think
gonzalez was like well i might have you
know i'm gonna go hang out with bronco
because he's got this thing going on
right eventually gone's bounced you know
uh
vision and joined up and started blind
with rocco
and jason lee right and i eventually
ended up on blind because
that was a contrived move because mike
trenansky was like hey danny's going to
quit h3 because he's not stoked
on what we're doing and mike kept saying
i'm butting heads with tony on some
things
i don't know the whole story behind it
but supposedly they weren't seeing eye
to eye
so mike was like you know let's just
meet with rocco and like let's figure
out how we can do something with him
but mike realizes it's going to take a
little while to make all this happen so
he's like i don't want to lose you so go
ride for rocco for a little bit
we'll figure this out and then we'll
just make it happen when the time's
right but at least you'll still be in
the in the in the mix you know
right so i jumped on blind for a while
and then eventually we
we got the you know the whole plan b
thing going and rocco was a big
part of plan b yeah going back to
scott's question are there beef between
isn't it yeah because i see that
competitions you know like when you're a
street and everybody's just kind of
standing there while the one guy skates
but like
behind the scenes are you guys like now
[ __ ] you well yeah i think the answer to
your question about is there beef
between skateboard companies
yes and not only that but there's like
secret
like you know like top big stars
defecting from their companies to go
start other companies
and then like nobody knows about it
until it actually happens and
there's all this backstabbing and
betrayal and like what do you mean like
they start a company while they're
still with another company and then as
soon as they get their company started
they're like
it's like getting another girlfriend
before you break up with the girlfriend
you've got yeah yeah
the first plan b ad was five of these
writers are gonna be leaving their
current sponsors to start a new company
and we had the list of all the top pros
on this ad
so it was like all of the all the
companies were going like oh [ __ ]
who's gonna be like they didn't know i
mean but if you look at our ad it's like
it's like everybody hawk i mean you name
it like you know all the top guys in
that time
we're on this list that we're gonna be
potentially leaving their current
sponsor to start plan b
so for like until the next ad dropped
which is like the next month where we
had
the team list you know the team writers
actually you know on that ad
for about a month you know people were
tripping like whoa who's like what's
happening here who's
who's gonna be leaving who you know like
that's so great i mean what about like
fights and stuff were there any other
physical stuff going down behind the
scenes or was it like at parties when
you ran into each other look at this
guy's face he's smiling about something
i mean i just i'm just thinking
skateboarders are
you know like and skateboard culture is
pretty [ __ ] cool man to be honest
like
despite how much you know like hey i
want to [ __ ] win this contest or i
want to do better
you know i think you know there's been a
couple you know i think people that have
beef
but not like you would think i think for
the most part for how rebellious
skateboarding has been over the years
and
you know it being kind of an outcast you
know industry or whatever or society
it's i think for the most part a lot of
respect and you know amongst each other
to be honest you know so
i i've you know i haven't seen too much
to be
on that level it's more than like
politics within
business culture yeah i've got it but
that doesn't equal this it's just more
of like
that guy just one-upped me with that
strategy okay how do we fire back
you know clever with cleverness and
effectiveness
it's like anything else there's more
fist fights over [ __ ]
right like dude you humped my girl
[ __ ] bop okay okay got it
it's not like a [ __ ] tribalism like
i'm part of this crew like you're
[ __ ] i mean
there is some of that but it's like it's
business you know
it's business and and yeah that's crazy
i've never heard about the ad
where it's like there's this new company
plan b and
we're gonna take five of these
five of these top pros are gonna be
leaving their current sponsors to start
a new brand
wow whose idea was that sounds like a
rocco idea to me
i think maybe mike and rocco can try
that but i'll send it to you and when
we're done with these things
so you can see it is i'm okay now on the
topic of
ads there's uh there's one that i
[ __ ] can like never there's actually
two ads i can never forget in
skateboarding that just blew my mind
one was it said the house that rodney
built and it listed every trick that
rodney mullin was responsible for
inventing and like that and the [ __ ]
the font size was so small to fit all
those words on one page
because he just invented it was
mind-boggling but then the other ad was
for danny way
and i think what i'd say like danny way
part man part machine and it listed like
all the surgeries that you'd had
yeah and it was just like oh my god
danny wade's been
just the most operated on athlete
like ever so we gotta ask like can you
can you run us through
your uh your surgeries before we hear
about how
unbelievably a lot of surgery danny's
had
let me tell you that recovering from
surgery does not mean you should not be
styling
hell no and if you think that with just
one arm that works that i'm not gonna
use my
fix your lid products you're out of your
mind
i'm gonna get my girl to do it she's all
dolled up looks honey
come on let me tell you about this while
you look at my hot chunk of puss
yeah your husband that's right now this
is a
fully american company 100 made in
america 100
cruelty free products that means that
they don't do any testing on animals
nothing like that my girls never even
checked out these products and look how
easily she's making them work
how are you gonna get them because you
need them right
yeah you do you go to the website which
is shop fixyourlid.com
use the promo code stevo and that gets
you 10
off at checkout plus doing that right
now
automatically enters you to win a
super cool cooler filled with fix your
lid
products which was personally signed by
me
yeah i signed a bunch of them and you
could have one so
again go to shopfixyourlid.com use the
promo code stevo
and get ready to be absolutely styling
just like me yeah dude all right
now let's talk surgery i have a little
bit of a catalog of surgeries that i've
acquired it was it was that was the ad
right you guys have the same
surgeon
yeah when i needed uh like 11 screws in
my ankle
danny brought me to his doctor yeah and
my [ __ ] worked great
i got you on the surgery list like a
week later and like normally most people
have to wait like
a few weeks or a month to get in to get
their appointment it takes a while you
know they're like
that's right he's a frequent flyer and
danny's had like
uh cadaver ligaments like shown in and
then they failed so then he went back
and got like synthetic
he's like and you guys have both done
the anesthesia challenge
like that's how you know you're [ __ ]
done a lot of surgeries
i want a rematch
damn but yeah walk us through the
surgeries
yeah well i mean you know they started i
think i had my first surgery at like 15
and i shattered my elbow and
it still doesn't straighten all the way
that's as far as i can bend it that way
and then that way it only goes
so that that was like the first like oh
[ __ ] i hurt myself that and i don't know
if it's ever going to be the same again
and that was kind of like humbling for
me for a minute i'm like well i can
actually damage my body beyond the point
of repair
oh [ __ ] what have i got myself into you
so you know i
i i had like a pretty good run cert
without
you know i had a pretty bad back injury
or spinal injury when i was 18 that
yeah he surfed into a rock and got
[ __ ] paralyzed for six months is that
right
i had not a hundred percent paralyzed
but paralysis i had for over a year like
i had a hard time moving my arms and
moving my limbs you know right i
couldn't stand up for very long i'd get
[ __ ] vertigo and lit
and dizzy i remember your brother dude
[ __ ] danny had his own video came out
in the skateboard industry
in like 1999 maybe 1998 and it was
called
danny way living legend right
i had it in that video his brother damon
said it would describe this injury that
danny had surfing where
he like went under and like hit like his
head into a rock
and and his brother described it as his
vertebrae in his neck were like
compressed
right it was a vertebrae injury which
which literally left him paralyzed you
know and so like
one of the the doctors didn't know what
to do and so danny goes to like
[ __ ] just disappears from the world
off the face of the earth goes to
hawaii to some like crazy like witch
doctor dude and like nobody hears from
you know and and nobody hears from them
they're thinking oh my god danny like
like for him to not have use of his body
is the saddest most tragic [ __ ] thing
and know what nobody was hearing from
him and then he shows back up like after
like six months a year or something
right goes to the biggest
[ __ ] contest in pro skateboarding
which is the tampa pro
and he shows up and wins [ __ ] first
place invert and second place in street
wow that's what's so rad about danny
throughout is that he's a full-on double
threat like any other pro skateboard is
pretty much
a half-pipe skater or a street skater
but danny's both
what the [ __ ] happened at the shaman in
hawaii
you know he he was more i wouldn't you
know it's not like some
witch doctor per se he was he's
definitely a different kind of holistic
doctor
more of a warrior but at that point i
was so desperate because i wasn't
getting any help from the western
doctors
you know i i saw some of the best
surgeons and orthopedic surgeons and
neurosurgeons or whatever in in the
country that weren't giving me any
positive
hope so i was like i can't just sit here
and not do
anything and it wasn't getting any
better so it took about a year and three
months
but there's a chain of events that
happened that led me to the guy that
actually like led me out of the woods on
this but it took me going to hawaii
staying with this guy for a couple
months and doing you know
he's like a kinesiologist chiropractor
nutritionist like
mental like a mentor like you know he
he got me back because i was pretty
depressed i was pretty i was like at a
point of like [ __ ] this if it doesn't
change you what's the point of being
alive kind of mentality
and you know that's shallow but at that
age it was a lot weighing in on me with
this but
how old were you so i went to hawaii he
said 18 18.
and so i went to hawaii worked with this
guy got my head back in the right space
where i was like motivated to like
keep fighting this and and then he was
like well you know you got to go home
sometime and
you know i got i can't you know take
care of you forever so
we've decided i was going to come back
to san diego and he was like i got
somebody i know there that you should
meet
and do some follow up with that's
somebody i used to work with so he
introduced me to one of his friends in
san diego and i went to him right when i
got back from hawaii
and this guy is like whoa you're a
pretty
pr pretty fragile case i don't know if i
want to do anything like i don't want to
take the responsibility with this this
is pretty serious
stuff you know so i was like oh my god
here we go again i'm back to square one
oh i remember what damon said he said
danny dislocated his brain
stem from his spinal cord
you can't do that or you would die what
i did is i i dislocate
what i did is i separated or i i tore
the ligaments that hold your atlas
vertebrae to the to your occiput to the
base of your skull
so so where your head sits on it's like
a cradle your atlas vertebrae holds
you know it's a cradle for your skull
that vertebrae was like
slid over and sitting on my spinal cord
because i tore the
ligaments that hold it in place so it
just was sitting there
and no doctor because there was no
broken bones could i
like you tell me you know chiropractor
could see it was out it was sit
it was out of place like 12 degrees or
something
but like they but the western doctors
were like there's no broken bones
it'll just heal and i'm like there's no
healing going on here
and it's like a broken wrist you know if
you broke your wrist and you didn't put
it in the cast and it was displaced
right it's going to heal displaced yeah
so i tore all the soft tissue with that
vertebrae sitting on my spinal cord it
healed like that
so like i wasn't going to get any better
these [ __ ] western guys are like dude
it'll heal over time just give it a time
and blah blah blah
get a year and three months in i'm like
dude i'm [ __ ] ready to lose my mind
here like for real
went to hawaii dude led me back to his
boy here and then he goes
i don't want to touch you but i know a
guy i don't know him very well but i've
heard about him his name is paul check
this guy is going to say he's going to
help you i think i'm like oh god here we
go
another guy so i go to this paul check
guy desperate again and
all i walk in he's like i know i can see
right now what's going on and i
understand it
you broke down exactly what i just said
to you about the vertebrae sitting on my
spinal cord
he can unwind it's going to take some
work follow his lead will be good
it went from literally suicidal
i dropped probably i was like 140 pounds
at this point i normally weigh 185
you know so it's like 40 pounds of
muscle because i i literally couldn't
move for my waist up for over a year
like i lost
all of my muscle up like anyways
so it was like you know i had to rebuild
myself but paul's like just trust me and
i'm at this point i'm just like dude i
don't
[ __ ] how can i trust anyone at this
point but he was you know just his
energy or whatever i i was like [ __ ] i
have nothing to lose i'm gonna follow
this guy's lead
and dude he led me out of the trenches
on this thing you know
not i mean i i still my whole life had
to deal with the repercussions i like
i'm not completely ever healed from that
like there's a residual and i just
consistently work at it to keep going
like he
got me back to a point in three months
after i met him where i went to tampa
and won the contest and got second in
the street one but that was like
from completely bedridden to three
months later wow
pretty pretty you know if i didn't go to
hawaii i wouldn't have found like it's
just the chain of events that led me to
these people
i don't know if i because paul check you
know my whole career now from that point
on he's my guy
what sort of stuff did he have you doing
for those three months like
i mean he went in there and manually
mobilized all those
all those vertebrae that were frozen and
all healed all out of place and all the
soft tissue you had to break all that
tissue up
and i was working with his chiropractor
buddy that does just atlas
alignments only he's an atlas specialist
so
i would bounce back from paul's physical
therapy office to this guy
kenny shepard this atlas guru where he
would set my atlas in place
and then you know paul would go and
break up all the soft tissue i'd get it
set in place
but by the end of the day it would slide
back out so i'd go back and get it set
again
and that for like a couple months
every day back and forth from one office
to the other
eventually my vertebrae started to hold
in the right place again
did you have health insurance covering
all this [ __ ] or was it just like
crazy bills dude this is like i mean
this is like
you know this is in the era where
skateboarders weren't making much money
you know i was i didn't have you know we
didn't have managers and a lot you know
i didn't have my parents driving my
career and managing me like i was pretty
much on my own at 16. you know
right so health insurance like i i wish
i had it but i didn't have it
so like when this [ __ ] went down it was
like every bit of money i had went into
me
chasing this and so i i got it you know
extremely broke in this time period too
and and didn't know what what to do i
was paying cash for everything
harsh reality health insurance when
you're 18 is like just drink more beer
[ __ ] it you know
hey dude this was the one time in my
life
like where i was literally shell shocked
so much that
like they were handing me like drugs
dude whatever you know they were giving
me
painkillers all i didn't take when this
happened i was so scared because of the
neurological problems i had
that i didn't touch any not one
painkiller
not one tylenol not one advil dude i was
so
religious about what i put in my body
after that because i was so scared i was
like
i couldn't even enjoy being it didn't
matter what i did
if i took something at that point i was
so you know intimidated by the re
by the all the neurological problems but
it didn't even matter if i was numb
on a painkiller psychologically i was in
hell so like
it's just like i just didn't even didn't
even go down that path
at all it was uh it was a long road
of of real reflection you know being at
that
being that like down and out and being
crystal clear about it
it's the best way i you know i couldn't
have dealt with it in a better way
because i was
numbing myself i might have took myself
out who knows so you're 18 years old
when you have the accident
and you're semi-paralyzed like how old
are you when you win that tampa contest
when you just reappear in the world
20 years old maybe so two years out it's
like a year and a half late i don't know
i think i was like 18 and a half when
that next thing happened i think it was
around 20.
and uh yeah it wasn't like it was you
know it was literally like a year and a
half after that injury
you know the neck injury was the
precursor to getting to the surgeries
although that was a major injury it
didn't need any surgical repair
it was a different kind of of
therapeutic or rehabilitation
strategy that got me out of that one but
um if
but i didn't start having surgery until
i was like
like consistently until i was about 30
years old oh okay
consistently i got through my 20s
i got through my 20s pretty unscathed i
was pretty you know other than
you know because i was trained like i
was this is you know also
the realization the wake-up call i had
when i went through that neck injury was
like
i have to earn this now because i had a
lot of weakness in my neck and like some
un irreversible damage still in there
even though i'm functioning
now if i don't take care of this like
i'm gonna i'm so vulnerable now i gotta
be in best shape i can
to deal with you know the the
repercussions of you know the mistakes i
make riding my skateboard or anything
else
that i'm doing so you know i started to
work really hard through my 20s
you know um to to be on a different
level which was
not cool in skateboarding yet you know i
had to like kind of be underground about
my
training mission like you know i didn't
want people to know like oh this guy's
like works out like he's not a
skateboarder because skateboarders don't
work out like
right i was like dude i just want to
skate whatever it takes i'm doing it so
yeah you know anyways now yeah danny
wants to list surgeries and i think
that's that's crucial yeah but i just
wanted to throw in there
that you got the surfing the
skateboarding and then
you've also got your professional
snowboarder
right and motocross
what yeah what the big five like racing
like top pro motocross stuff or even you
know i was
i was in the moto i was getting good at
it and i decided at a certain point like
is this
worth it was after the neck injury when
i started to really weigh out like what
should i be doing and what shouldn't
now i know i can get hurt i didn't
realize i was that
like before the neck injury i was like
getting hurt it's like whatever
you felt right i didn't know that you
can get that hurt
you know and he beat dave mara in a
downhill
bicycle competition really
to win like a hundred thousand dollars
yeah and yeah
you know it's just it's borderline
creepy how much i know about danny
but uh but yeah so what was on that ad
when
the the ad that listed all of your uh
your surgeries
i mean uh i can't even i'll do my i mean
i've had like
probably like eight different surgeries
on my left knee
you know like there's been four acl
reconstructions and a bunch of just
minor meniscus or or cartilage cleanups
and stuff like that
i've had what a you know like probably
roughly around five surgeries on my
ankle
from when i broke it jump in the gray
wall of china
that's that's cost me a pretty good you
know that one's just
the deterioration on that one's just
going downhill from at this point but
um shoulder elbow i've had several on
like i've had
several surgeries on the same joints
because i've just keep damaging them
but i've had both my shoulders
reconstructed
my knees ankle elbow wrist
i mean pretty much almost every joint my
body's had surgery
it's unbelievable well where do you want
to go to next because i have questions
right okay well here here we go so we've
got like
you know you turned pro when you were
14. yeah
sure okay turn progress paralyzed when
he was 18.
you know on top of the world again when
uh when he was 20
now 23 is
when uh i was was i 20
[ __ ] i was 22 years old when i got
sponsored by
danny's company xyz clothing and and
they were sponsoring me
for drinking bong water and lighting
myself on fire like that was
and and i was on the team list which is
so [ __ ] crazy
and uh they flew me out to san diego
to shoot an ad for xyz before i even
went to clown college
and uh little did i know that
when i'm out there and danny's pulling
together he's going to set the world
the world record for the highest air
ever done
and and he did and he built the first uh
skateboarding mega ramp yeah
how did that happen like i mean this it
was mike turnosky's idea right
like uh it was you and mike said well
dude
i i know a way to do the the highest air
because they had always as as soon as
they had half pipes and people started
doing
going into the air above the ramp they
were measuring it
like immediately and and through
all of the 1980s it was just a
battle for inches and millimeters
you know like that the highest air was
sitting somewhere around like
eight feet you know and then it went
like to nine feet but they were always
but it was like it would only ever like
incrementally go up
like the tiniest little amount like
hovering around nine feet
if i'm if i'm right and then danny just
comes and danny
builds this [ __ ] gigantic ramp with a
huge roll in
and just blows it out of the [ __ ]
water takes the highest air ever done
from nine feet
all the way up to 16 feet and just rub
it in
he did a [ __ ] kick flip air where he
you know you flip the board
he did that 12 and a half feet above the
ramp and and
and i'm speaking for danny here but wha
but what drove him
drove him nuts what drove danny nuts
about all of this
was that the the 16-foot air didn't get
as much attention not even the 12 and a
half foot kickflip
indy but what got all the attention was
that they were filming from a helicopter
and danny looks at the helicopter he's
like oh let me jump out of the
helicopter
into the ramp and that was what got the
[ __ ] cover of the magazine
not the big air but danny jumping out of
a helicopter and the whole world's like
oh my god the guy [ __ ] jumped out of
a helicopter and landed in a ramp and
like danny's like
but but the air yeah that was extreme
yeah i wasn't even like i was like the
heli thing was cool whatever
you know but i was so much more proud
about breaking the world record but
everyone's like dude that was cool but
the helicopter shit's on another level
dude
i couldn't figure it out i'm like well i
don't get it and then okay
and then speaking of [ __ ] up injuries
okay
danny like uh they set up some mtv event
right so so danny's going to jump out of
the helicopter
for this uh for for mtv but
it's a music festival yeah and for this
friend so while he's trying it
he [ __ ] jumps out but he doesn't get
it and he completely dislocates his
shoulder
[ __ ] shoulders out and danny says
harley's scar from that one that was a
marley surgery [ __ ] it sucked it
started
the shoulders out and and what did you
pop it back in and he says dude
i gotta get back up in that [ __ ]
helicopter and jump out real quick
before this [ __ ] gets tight and sore
so he goes up and he jumps out of the
helicopter
with the dislocated shoulder and [ __ ]
makes it
wow you want to explain that in these
situations it's like
you've already damn you know i've
already blew out my shoulder what am i
going to sit there and be like oh this
sucks watching or i could
what if i could have tried it what if i
made it i knew it wasn't that
complicated i just need to get up there
and do it again and get it over with
and it's a lot easier going into a
surgery or whatever knowing you at least
got
the goal that you accomplished like
under your belt you know like
i could justify the next monday morning
going in the surgery room like
well thank god i got the helicopter
thing done but rolling in there with a
blown shoulder with no clip
i'm doing it okay yeah so
now here's another example what the
[ __ ] uh went
at the x games right and this would have
been the x games in
2008. danny goes on this
now it's like the real mega danny goes
up and
[ __ ] as he comes back down he clips
his
topples front over yeah he clips his
feet on the edge of the ramp and just
takes the
most [ __ ] brutal slam ever and you
were knocked unconscious
on that one right no i had the wind
knocked out of me but i i didn't
go unconscious on that i was rattled it
was
i wanted to be unconscious but i would
have yeah
up to that point it was the most brutal
slam that we had ever seen
at the x games and danny goes back up
and they're like you gotta go to the
hospital he says [ __ ] that i'm going
back up and do it again he goes back
up and makes the run did you get gold
i got second place you know like yeah i
i i yeah i mean i mean dude much respect
to bob brunk was of course for taking
that but like
there's one art if there's one event
where i'm like dude
did you break anything during that i
broke my my foot
did they try to give you a wheelchair
they tried to carry me off the ramp
which i would you know like i was just
so with the broken foot you're like
i'm [ __ ] going again yeah and okay
here's another one
okay danny goes like this is the biggest
deal ever like uh
danny jumped over the great wall of
china
right like no like the the the relations
between america and china have never
been really that great you know it was a
big deal to get permission
from china to go over there and jump a
skateboard over the wall what year
uh 2005 yeah yeah i think it was five
yeah yeah and so he goes over there on
the [ __ ] practice run
did you broke your ankle or your foot
that was my ankle
yeah so he broke his [ __ ] ankle like
doing a practice run the day before
day before a day of day before
like the i wasn't supposed to take any
practice run but i could smell like i'm
like dude
they didn't they didn't they didn't
translate the
the dimensions correctly from metric to
or from standard to metric
language barrier some things came out
wrong on the ramp and i was like
visually like
whoa i can already tell like some shit's
not going to feel exactly how
it normally does so i was adamant about
taking a test run before
you know the day before the government
was like you better not like it's
forbidden
because somebody's going to get a photo
or a video and i was like i'm going to
[ __ ] die if this in front of
everybody i'm [ __ ] figured out right
now
right so i took the test run right
before dark and
just like i thought there wasn't enough
roll in
right i came up short and landed on the
deck right
was another flaw because most of the
decks on these landing ramps
i always build them half the angle from
like 45
to vertical like yeah
they put a flat deck with a sharp edge
on it normally i build like a roller
over the edge so if i did come up short
i could at least like get a little
forgiveness going in but dude it was
like a square edge like this and i was
like a foot short dude a foot like i
could see the edge and i'm like
do i go head first and try and swan dive
or do i take it and i was like dude if i
come up short
this way i'm going to die and this is
all happening in real time like
milliseconds of thoughts like okay which
way do i roll with this
and so instinctually i put my feet out
first and i landed on that edge of that
deck and cartwheeled down the thing and
fractured my ankle the night before the
next day
with the [ __ ] broken ankle he comes
back
and jumps over the [ __ ] great wall of
china
like and not and then and then that
wasn't even good enough he goes back
up and does a backside 360 air over the
great wall of china
i did five 360s in a row
if i didn't break my ankle i would have
sessioned that i was like my goal was
like
to get like a film a segment like get a
bunch of tricks on video over the great
wall and make it its own thing
that was my fantasy i didn't realize i
was gonna break my ankle yeah
and and so at the end of the day there
there are how many people
have their name in gold on the great
wall of china
like five yes um like that
i'm the only american though yeah who's
the first five people in the world
i don't know dude
yeah it's a funny one i should do a
little research on that but i never
really
yeah i mean danny's not a big like
stealth
patter on the backer yeah jesus dude
right i'm just like where's the next
opportunity to jump the next thing you
know which
is i'm in real time right now i've got
something on my plate that's
you know i was when we talked the other
yet a couple days ago steve i was out in
el centro looking at the border the
the trump wall you know yeah danny calls
you up the other day
and uh i'm like oh yeah dude just came
back from like getting hit in the balls
like and he's like oh i'm getting ready
to jump over a [ __ ] border wall
i'm like dude we're old you know
we're older we're still doing this [ __ ]
you know dude
who would have thought you know i mean
like when i was a kid like
you know the guys that were 30 skating
we were like
look at this old man trying to escape
dude and i'm looking at bucky at
47 or whatever just ripping and bunny
new tricks
it's a different era dude it's like i
didn't even thought we would get to this
point and like
i'm sure like we were living by day by
day we were younger like it didn't it
wasn't like a five-year plan or a
three-year plan it was like a 24-hour
plan
for sure and when when we were kids
there was no such thing as like a
rock star over 30 or an athlete over 30
right like you're
yeah i mean maybe the [ __ ] rolling
stones are like we're
40 i don't know but that was [ __ ] up
i mean it definitely you know things
have evolved in this area you know like
you can
yeah it's it's pretty cool that we're
able to still
you know you get kicked in the balls
amigo you know try and make these wall
jumps nothing i mean since you brought
it up
like what's the story with the the trump
border wall like what's the
i mean i i i'm not like a politic guy so
it's don't
i hope people don't you know i i'm
actually wrong it's it's shock
value it's like okay there's
controversial over the wall there's
controversy over the
you know the pres all the elections
right now and you would probably
understand this more than anyone from
like um
from like a you know a media standpoint
there's other things that you know that
that would be nice to shine light on
like
you know the border you know politics
separate people the border separates
people based on politics but the people
are
you know my friend that races trophy
trucks who's mexican is the one that got
us the permission on
the mexico side so we were both going to
jump it he's going to jump in his trophy
truck i'm going to jump it on my
skateboard
but the idea is is like it's a new
mexican and american jumping it it's
like
we're all good dude the politics
separated us not people people
people the people we love each other
it's just no separation i like that
so what you're going to do the same
thing like you did in the great wall of
china
yeah this is a little different uh it's
a little different style because of how
what the wall is it's just a different
layer like type of wall it's like tall
to me it would be funnier if like there
wasn't a wall because isn't there like
not a wall
yeah is there a wall are they do they
build the wall
see this wall is like 40 feet tall with
like barbed wire
like it's a gnarly is it new gnarly
stunt i feel like that gives more credit
than is deserved though because i don't
think trump's built [ __ ]
right that's something that's just
always been there huh he's built some
stuff
and he started they started building it
in like san ysidro right you know the
border between
you know embryo beach and san diego but
we went out
east a little bit because we know people
that own private property out there i'm
working with like the head of the border
patrol and
um and i've been working with the mayor
of imperial beach and like we've been
trying to hone our team to get this done
but it's going to be a lot easier to do
on private property than federal
property so i found these
locations that we know people own these
these properties but they're
east a little bit but the wall there is
pre-existing although it's still
35 feet tall and five feet of barbed
wire on the top of it
i don't know where the [ __ ] trump thinks
he needs to build a different wall this
wall
is serious dude like it's no joke i'm
like looking at this thing like what
why would you need to replace this wall
so funny if anything get rid of it all
together
when's the last time you had a surgery
um it's been a little bit
um when we were like probably five four
or five years
oh was that the last anesthesia
challenge yeah yeah yeah
so what was that can we explain that for
people you guys each got anesthesia and
tried to see who could last longer or
something correct
yeah it's uh the anesthesia challenge is
when they
when they put you under you fight it and
so you see who can fight it for the
longest and stay awake
and uh it seems that i i'm more of a
drug addict in my history because i have
like a little built-in
uh tolerance maybe more because i've
lasted marginally longer yeah because
we've done it a couple times
we've done it twice but the second time
we're gonna do it
we brought down a bunch of dildos and we
brought down like tattoo guns and like
we all went into the surgery room and
then once we pulled out the dildos
they were like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing
well they're like yeah we're gonna we're
gonna intubate them with a dildo
where did this where did you do this one
had it was when i went to get the
surgery or sorry
when i went to get the hardware out of
my ankle oh [ __ ]
yeah so i wish i would have known we
could have had a rematch yeah yeah
fantasy challenge is a pretty awesome
event
we got to get you guys side by side that
was where i came up with the idea to
get anesthesia while i was riding a
bicycle and we [ __ ] went down the
rabbit hole on that whole idea
if you could put like you know like a
little sensor in the pillow so when your
head taps it like
sends up
[Applause]
two people laying next to each other
like holding their head up like i got
this
that's probably the only thing you could
beat danny way at steve
something drug-related right yeah
stunt game is ridiculous so that's
really i mean i
you know i i've always you know when i
first seen this guy i was like
this guy's going to be a world-class
stunt man like you know and i saw that
i saw the you know my my own little
vision in my mind was like this guy is
going to bring rock stars into
stuntman to the stunt thing you know
like there isn't really like
other than evil knievel which you know
he's obviously
known for what he did motorcycles and
you know whatever his rocket jumped over
this yeah
stun men were anonymous yeah they've
always been anonymous so i saw like
steve was like whoa this guy is going to
be like
the first like mainstream celebrity
stunt man
were you at the trade show when tommy
met steve nah that didn't
that was just tommy that one was in
orlando was this expo in orlando
yeah yep and then and then did tommy
come back and show you this guy's video
i'm like dude we just picked this guy up
he did he's like i got and tommy's such
got a gift for like
you know finding things that are like
special like
like talent you know or just he's got a
knack for like
you know fine if tommy makes an intro
the guy's special
you know that's when tommy says like
dude this guy's
you know like i i you know i understand
tommy's mentality so well that like when
i saw the light in his eyes like dude i
met this guy and i think he's going to
bring a lot to the table
let's fly him out here and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah let's get him out here and
how long before jackass is this this is
like that was i
it was january 97 and um i went to clown
college in the summer of 97.
so yeah like would have been like may
do you remember what when it was that
you did that uh jump out of the
helicopter
16-foot air thing uh september
1997. oh okay oh [ __ ]
then uh it was more than a couple weeks
after i was there
oh wait it was august august same summer
but on the issue the the issue of
transworld skateboarding that had danny
jumping out of the helicopter on the
cover
like had an xyz ad with me blowing a
fireball
in the uh in new mexico yeah
that that had um me and simon eddie with
the 50 50 fireball
that's cool do you think you're in a
like white white one suit yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
suit the motorcycle you got that article
i'm sure [ __ ] yeah that's it's the same
photo that
there's all the posters of okay danny do
you have a favorite photo of all the
years
you uh you know i don't know oh dude
then they're like the
the [ __ ] cool yeah of course there
are
yeah i mean dude danny
danny like went okay so danny built that
one he did the 16-foot air
and what that was was just a big roll in
with like a
humongous quarter pipe basically but
then
danny said all right now i've set the
record
for the highest error ever done but what
i want to do
is set the record for the longest air
ever done
so that he built the the the mega ramp
as we know it now with the huge roll in
and
the giant house like elliot's house and
what danny did
was he didn't he didn't just set both
records
he did them back to back right he did
the longest air ever done
like uh straight into the highest error
ever done
in one run oh [ __ ] and the longest air
ever done he set the record
he did a backside 360 air longer than
anybody i'd ever done
was that premeditated or were you like
uh after you did that one you're like no
[ __ ] i'm gonna do the next one
no i i think i realized at a certain
point i was like i think i could
probably break both records in one run
because
you know by default you know the quarter
pipe
after the jump was like essentially like
what am i gonna do to slow down without
like it became like
a realization that like i have a lot of
speed and it's hard to get this kind of
speed it takes a lot of money to build
rollins to get to speed if i'm going to
build a quarter pipe with a rolling it's
good so i realized
i got to do something with this speed
what can i build now and when i put the
quarter pipe there i realized like okay
this is the kind of speed i need to
break the world you know to do the
highest error but
yeah it was like a goal i had was like
break two world
records in one run it was part of the
pitch i had to throw at dc to like get
him to help me
fund the thing you know sick oh dude so
so what was that record it was a
like it was a 60 foot backside 360 air
landed and then five oh 75 foot back
saying 360 air
into what was like a 24 foot
high air i think it was like 20 23.5
23.5 close enough that's amazing so
the record his own record went from 16
feet high
to 23.5 feet high but
having just done a 75 foot long
who do you still have the record yeah
i broke the higher record i broke both
of those records since
you know not the distance one is like 79
feet now and then the higher one is 25
and a half feet now
and you both you hold both of those yeah
what have you what have you broken more
records or bones
[Laughter]
i guess more ligaments than bone
ligaments yeah yeah
i haven't you know i've broken some
bones but mostly torn ligaments
okay mostly you know i got a few records
in there in the middle of breaking some
bones and tearing ligaments for sure
have you accomplished all your goals or
do you still have a couple that you're
like just
itching to do and pull the trigger on oh
i'm always my brain is always
trying to calculate something and you
know part of the part of the excitement
of doing this stuff is the chase to
achieve it
so it's like i always you know even
though it might be unachievable i'm
always giving to myself it is achievable
and you know as long as you relentlessly
put in the work to keep trying to
achieve then part of the excitement's
there even though you haven't
accomplished it yet you know so
there was another one that was going on
in uh
in vegas with like the rooftops
one rooftop to the next and that's so
yeah the rooftop transfer at the hard
rock yeah
that got shut down by the hard rock the
hard rock one fell apart because of the
weight
load on the c uh you know the ramp i
needed to build
with the wind load you know because
these are tall towers and they're going
to put it on the roof of the building
they got to strap that tower down and
vegas gets some pretty heavy winds
so basically they couldn't calculate all
they knew that the weight of the
structure was already pushing the
the load limit but then adding the wind
they were like dude we can't take a risk
so the last second i had everything
queued up to jump
from building the building at vegas or
at the hard rock vegas and uh
and they pulled the plug on me which
would have been my i think my coolest
stunt because i was gonna flat ground
street ollie
because it's like a step down so i
wasn't gonna have a jump i was just
gonna hit it and flat ground all these
down stories
[ __ ] yeah and i think the answer to your
question scott
is uh no danny hasn't done everything
that
he wants to do and that the the
qualifier for that answer is that
if at any point you're not scheming to
do
something new then you might as well not
be alive anymore
100 yeah yeah yeah
in nature if you're not growing you're
dying right true you gotta keep
progressing now
stay ripe or you'll go rotten yeah you
want to stay alive
dude you want to stay alive let's go
back though to when
my initiation with meeting stevo oh yeah
i mean dude this one i i know it's going
to be a part of the
the main channel video because i saw the
footage
in the pappas brothers documentary they
actually have me doing it there so
we'll pull that footage out of there i
don't think we need to have too much
overlap but dude i'll tell you uh the
first time i ever wore the cheetah print
bikini
was when we went out there to to hug
sharks
and the idea to hug sharks was a hundred
percent danny ways
he he he got me on the phone he said
dude stevo
i got an idea it's called shark hugging
we're gonna catch a blue shark
and when it's on the line we're gonna
reel it up to the boat and you jump in
the water and [ __ ]
hug it while it's on the line and in my
mind
i thought okay like by the same
principle that like a compass
and geometry you know you can make a
circle if the length of that fishing
line
is only so far then the head of that
blue shark won't be able to
so if i come from behind it's safe
but that was a [ __ ] awful idea and
blue sharks are so pissed
so we went yeah blue sharks are so
pissed they're so big they're the
[ __ ]
angriest shark dude like blues and bulls
have like more testosterone than
elephants i think
and uh and so we went and did it with
nurse sharks and that was where my first
time swimming with a shark and i managed
to get bitten
by a nurse shark which like you have to
be you have to be an extraordinary
imbecile to get bitten by a nurse shark
so but but when so when tommy told you
about steve
how long did it take for you to actually
meet him like where did you guys first
meet uh
it was mayor june i want to say june
yeah june of 97. it was when we wasn't
it wasn't long after the surf expo tommy
was like like
couple weeks or something like tommy got
you out like he was like
it was it was a few months but as soon
as i met danny
i think that there was some other guys
on the team too like the xyz team danny
was on board tommy's on board
but the idea that this [ __ ] [ __ ]
who sets himself on fire is on the team
list he's not even a skater
was kind of offensive to some of the
other team guys and so
when uh when when they flew me out to
san diego
it was like all right and i'm going to
meet everybody and these guys are kind
of looking at me
like [ __ ] sideways a little bit you
know like oh like what the [ __ ]
so what are you doing you're just like
smashing beer bottles in your head
right and uh and everybody was hanging
out [ __ ] uh
you know in danny's living room [ __ ]
doing bong hits
and i feel that genre it was my friend's
house by the way okay
my house was a little bit more
controlled environment but
that scene was like dude just a couch of
people doing bongits all day long
right okay but but everybody's around it
was like you know a bunch of guys on the
team and it was like
[ __ ] like i grabbed the bong and and
[ __ ] just
not knock it back i'd drink all the bong
water put it down empty and like then
everyone's like
all right we get it like that kind of
went i think that
that won everybody over a little bit
stevo came in and like was like hey
what's up what's up steve steve steve
and then like
oh can i get a bong hit like oh yeah
here and this
and this wasn't just a normal bong hit
these guys were smoking mall hits all
day with tobacco in there so like the
water was pretty
you know it was pretty murky with just
like you know
nicotine like i never i think they were
using heart rolls and [ __ ] back then
dude so like i'm sure there was a bunch
of chemicals and [ __ ] in that water
and that bong wasn't cleaned it was so
dirty steve comes in
sits down asked for bongit and we're
like sure pack them i'm all hit
rips the thing holds it in for a second
then chugs the [ __ ] bomb on water and
then blows out the hit
and we were just like what dude no way
he didn't he didn't claim anything he
didn't like he didn't promote this he
just sat down and did it
and like whoa dude it was this guy this
is crazy
and then uh i think it was like the next
day dude he was doing you know
gainers fireball gainers off the
trestles
with handcuffs on into the into the into
the um
you know lagoon it was the fire
breathing the handcuffed fire breathing
gainer flip off the bridge was my first
xyz yet
and that's what we shot on that trip
that's sick i don't know if i ever saw
that one
handcuffed yeah handcuffed and then and
the cops came
we lit the whole fight with the top of
the bridge was like train tracks and it
was like all wood like
i needed a good amount of fire to set
myself on fire to do the fire breathing
flip
and so the cops saw this fire on the
[ __ ] bridge and they come down and
they're like oh
[ __ ] so like the the xyz
clothing receptionist they had like this
hot chick and they took the tape and
like stuffed it in her bra
and we're like oh we don't know dude
[ __ ] we came here to film in the [ __ ] we
forgot the tape
yeah how i mean how many times before
that have you drinking bong water at
parties was that like a weekly thing or
is that like
it wasn't like super rare but that's
that was a special occasion kind of
trick did you know you're gonna do that
before or you're like
i gotta do something yeah i don't think
i knew i was gonna do that before but it
was a big deal for me to meet danny dude
you know
like it's like danny from like
he was my childhood hero you know being
the same age
and like you know he was a street skater
like
you cannot understate the importance of
what you brought to skateboarding by
having that vision to set the highest
air
and to push it further to do the longest
and the highest like and then
from when you did that and set those
records then
the following year it was june of 2003
that you set those records on the first
true mega
and the next year they they brought the
mega ramp to
the the x games which was in l.a
and like you're on the [ __ ] mega ramp
at the
staples center like while i'm
getting dragged out of the staples
center by [ __ ] security because i'm
all [ __ ] cockeyed drunk [ __ ]
pissing on everything
we were on a good one were you invited
there or like why were you there
i can't remember i think i was invited i
feel like maybe i was gonna present
something or other but i was just such a
[ __ ] drunken pile of [ __ ] that they
dragged me out what year was that in
2000 i think it was 2004. oh so
okay so you're already famous and maybe
it was 2005. i don't know but like
pretty quick that they got the mega ramp
into the x games like after you built
the first one
yeah i mean i pitched you know that was
that was two point i mean
there was a bigger picture vision along
the whole way like i'm personally not
like
could really give a [ __ ] about world
records you know like it's cool to know
you built something and you went you
know you push the limits of
possibility and all that that's like
what intrigues me the most
but to sell these things to get the
money and to like get people to
i have to like throw those those little
pieces in there yeah
it's like you know that's marketable and
that's something you know it tells a
story so
that being said you know i had to kind
of package it that way
but the bigger goal was like yeah i have
something here i know that can be
potentially a competitive event platform
and if i can just prove all this
which was the dc video then i could go
to espn and go
proof of concept is here look at the
response you know dude [ __ ]
epic worked out great you know and
that's essentially how
big air started at x games right and now
there's a whole new generation of mega
ramp skaters who have come up like
how many guys obviously elliot sloan
is at the top of the heap but like how
many guys would you say
are like really on top of the mega ramp
right now
i mean it's it's like because there's
not really any permanent i mean bob's
got one
elliot's got the mini mega which is
about like half the size
you know like um which is great for
practice and training
um but like there's no they're not that
accessible so it's kind of an elite
group of guys that have to have like
you got to be homies with bob you got to
be homies with elliot
it's not like anyone could get in this
group so it's like you know it's
a little yeah it's a it's a little bit
uh exclusive on that level but there is
a there you know the guys do penetrate
the bubble and get in there and get in
with
bob and get in with elliott and once
that happens you're home free
but getting to that point so you know i
i haven't i don't know what it takes
i haven't been at that level why this is
all unfolding i you know i was able to
get in ahead of it and start the thing
and
not have to worry about that part of it
but there is a solid group of guys that
are doing it you know i mean if you look
at like clay criner he's [ __ ]
nuts um you know look at what mitchie's
doing like did the 1260 or whatever
and um you know trey wood
like there's there's there's a bunch of
young guys that are ripping
obviously tom shark can skate that thing
pretty good
yeah but anyways there's there is a new
generation of guys that are
ripping you know but it's a small group
i mean how many dudes in the world do
the mega like
could you say it's under 50 i mean maybe
maybe close to that all-inclusive but
there's like
probably 10 guys that can you know
really through like move the needle for
it you know like that are in there like
they can compete for you know a winning
event
you guys all part of a facebook facebook
group
you told me the other day that you were
uh that you got a new video part
that you're putting out like uh yeah how
long have you been working on that
i mean like a few years i've just been
lightly chipping away at it just because
i
have this ramp in hawaii it's it's a
mega ramp but it's not like
one it's not like a jump it's not the
typical version it's a new version i
built
to be able to allow more like technical
vert skating possibilities
like more street minded stuff street
skating influence stuff
so it's it's been so hard to document
skateboarding over there because of
just the weather and then just getting
people out there and the time it takes
and
you know i just don't have somebody on
deck to basically go let's go film right
now
when i'm out there it's so hard to get a
production going there so
every trick that i film there it has
been so involved to like fly somebody
out for five days before they want to go
back home
just people in the like it's it's it's
so great it's so like in the wild there
that there's just like
mosquitoes and just you know if you're
hanging out filming dude you gotta like
be laced up with so much sunscreen
and mosquito spray and right it's just
not a pleasant it's
it's a gnarly environment to film
skateboarding yeah so with that being
said i've
you know over the few years i've chipped
away at enough footage i think now to
put out
um a video part if it was if i had this
ramp around the corner it would be a lot
more lucrative as far as
content goes but just the way it is it's
like i didn't realize it when i built it
that it was going to be like this but it
is
so so anyways the culmination is i
finally have a video apart
i collabed with metallica jesus did
so i got a metallica video or song and
it's you know metallic
dealt directly with you know metallica
myself to get the permission and
so i'm pretty hyped on that because i
pirated their stuff when i was younger
sure
revolution video we just ripped off
their songs we're fans like
we're like they can't hate on this funny
though because colin mckay
ends up being becoming managed by mark
writers are uh metallica's manager
um call ends up getting managed by mark
you know back you know maybe i don't
know in the mid 2000s or something
and so they start you know having the
conversation you know and colin's like
hey check this out show some revolution
and they're like
this [ __ ] yeah they didn't have their
horsemen but there was there was no
youtube back then you didn't need to get
the clearance and stuff you know so
they were all about it so they know that
colin and i i've used metallica in the
dc video i used orion but i
i did license that correctly but they
respect that i've
got a little bit of a theme going with
the video parts
so colin has a little section in this
hawaii video too so it's kind of
i it's like it's like a 2.0 revolution
nice dude oh did you put on the hesher
[ __ ] mullet wigs
we didn't do the wig dude we didn't go
that far but
there's a little section where colin's
like you'll see
air guitar on the skateboard in the
middle of the on the ramp in hawaii but
yeah i love it man we've been we've been
trying to come up with a plan for a
hawaii trip
for some time now man and uh the idea
was like
let's go to kauai to danny's compound
let's
swim with sharks with ocean ramsey you
got the hook up with helicopters in
hawaii
i got hookups for pretty much everything
in kauai yeah
it's a good community there's a lot of
like uh there's a lot of people that
have
good resources and everyone's pretty you
know helpful so it's easy to
to get things going so if you guys did
want to make that happen of course
i'm aborted to like i'm in the process
of
of selling my home right now to be able
to move over there to like really
hone my because the ramp over there gets
so overgrown and it's just like
oh [ __ ] i'll disappear for a few months
and show up and i can barely even see
the ramp and it takes me two weeks to
get it
to dig it out of all of the all of the
like foliage that grows over it and like
getting it all skateable again so i'm
just like ready just to be there
and to manage it day to day and start
building some new stuff
but the only way i'm going to do it if
i'm over there so anyways i'm sorry to
make a leap
over there for good permanently oh yeah
i'll be in california a bit but i'm just
saying like soon i'll be there full time
enough where you guys should come over
and i'll have things dialed in
yeah [ __ ] yeah i did calm down i'd love
to i i wanted to uh
like it occurs to me that like the plan
b is just so big now
you got sheckler you got torrey pudwell
like
pj lads oh tory left
he's well not in a bad not you know no
different than p-rod we're all friends
dude i'm proud of these guys for taking
and doing
exactly what i did i started my own
company that tori started thank you with
day one
oh gotcha okay yeah and p rods started
primitive so all i do is pat these guys
on the back and say rad you know i'm
glad you guys are maturing and doing
this stuff
oh yeah is there a more dominating
street skating part than tory pud will's
part at the end of the true video
dude tori is one of the most badass
street skaters of all time
it's one of my favorites for sure is
there anything everybody
touch that i don't you know
i mean you know you know opinion
everyone's got their opinion on
everything
i'm i'm i'm with you i'm a huge fan of
sorry's work and especially that
you know different style i mean i'll
give it to nij his till death part is
gnarlier
like it's the gnarliest but as far as
just technical
[ __ ] like yeah no
freaky freaky freaky tricks man like
super creative i wonder if that part's
gonna hunt tori
forever because it's like [ __ ] how am i
gonna follow that up
i mean i see him dropping clips in
recent time and i'm like
wow dude this guy's still got it so well
okay which is great because he had a
back injury that was there was a concern
yeah
but he's an anomaly talent right i think
we've digressed at that point and uh
you know [ __ ] dude like i would love
to go to hawaii and [ __ ] around there
and uh dude as always man i've always
said it dude like i know it's
it sounds kooky but you've always been a
hero to me dude and that just remains
the case dude so thank you for doing
this with us
you know i love you to dust even to be
honest like i'm a fan of you and that
you know like i'm very proud of you dude
like to see the evolution of of what
you've done with your career and
and you know what you've done with
yourself and you know you've
you've you've experienced everything to
the fullest
you know you've had a stunt you've had
to be the stunt dummy for a lot of other
people
yeah and but to be able to rebound from
that and be like check this out
this is if you're going to do it don't
even com you can never compete with this
see why even try
it's been done yeah but like you know
the the
i'm i'm very proud of you dude to see
how well you've done with your with your
life dude and
the opportunities that you were given
and that's all you know when i first met
you that's like i saw
i saw the passion in you i saw the dream
i saw it all like i
i knew you had the wiring to do this you
know so
it's pretty rad when you see your
friends accomplish what they were cut
out
you know what they were made to do what
they were what their purpose is you know
on this planet is for and i think
you have done a good job of entertaining
people pushing the needle on
making you know what what's comfortable
and what's not what's life-threatening
and what's not like
you walk the edge of the cliff on all of
it so fine dude and so hard that
it's it's pretty rad to be your friend
dude dude that means the world to me
danny dude
it's it's been [ __ ] rad just being
bros for
as long as we have dude i can think
there's so many things i can think of
that we didn't even bring up like
you know just so many rad experiences
dude and uh i just
i just love you back dude thank you so
much danny yeah
oh yeah dude yeah dude what can i say
danny way is a legend and a hero and i'd
really love it if he would shoot some
positive feedback his way
man whether you were a fan before or not
just
post away tag him let him know you
enjoyed that
and i gotta ask you this are you
subscribed to this podcast
i mean be a crying shame if you weren't
but you had to
get subscribed man but buy one of these
uh
signature dicks oh yeah it's the old
dickograph
dude the hustle's real i can't believe
i'm doing all of this
with uh the condition that i'm in and
you know it's just work work work man
what a deal yeah dude thank you guys